I've got a voicemail for you here our
voicemail number is two one nine to
david p the voicemail relates to the
story we did or we answered an audience
question last week about loaning money
to friends and family and the eggman
called in and connected producer pats
responds to that audience question to
producer pat talking about his
conservative family members take a
listen to this I thought it was really
funny how Pat said his immediate family
members were conservative some
supporters and he could debate stuff
with them and then he also said twenty
minutes later he would not only loan
that money he would just give them money
with no expectations of having it
returned I wonder if it is conservative
family members would loan him the money
the same way he would loan it to them
Pat is that a fair question Pat I mean
is there any reason to think that the
ink in incongruous politics of you and
some family members might impact their
willingness to help you financially if
you were finding yourself in such a
situation I don't think the eggman here
realizes that I have a huge family and
while there are plenty of conservatives
in my family there are plenty of
liberals too I mean I think they would
lend me money if I was a need even
though they're right-wingers I don't
think I think you got to put family
ahead of politics on this one would they
expect the money back though well I just
think that they would give me the same
offer that I gave to them which is
here's some money if you're able to pay
me back pay me back if you can't so it
goes you know I think they would
reciprocate and give the same offer as I
would to that fair enough well which is
this an unfair question from the eggman
I don't know we never see the eggman so
feisty is that a fair assessment
he seems agitated yeah no doubt about
that I certainly agree with that on the
bonus show today I'm going to talk to
you about high school teenagers that
invented a straw that could detect
common date rape drugs in drinks I'm
also going to talk to you about someone
who wants their genitals removed to
become a genderless alien
it's an odd story but a real story and
also I'm going to tell you about an
upcoming new sponsor on the david
package
very very cool stuff going on all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
how do you get instant access to the
Members Only daily bonus show you might
know the answer to that by now I've
mentioned this before you go to david
pakman.com slash membership if you want
a discount off of the normal membership
rates you can use the coupon code
I voted 17 and of course we are taking
pledges in any amount even as little as
$1 per month at patreon.com slash David
Pakman show
I'll talk to you on the bonus show